oggi finalmente dopo non so neanche
quanto tempo andiamo avanti con su
motori.it rings terzo episodio mi sogno
la notte la gente che mi chiedeva vj fi
su motori perché raga e allora vi spiego
proprio brevissimamente perché voglio
iniziare prima possibile
non faccio spesso sui motori raga perché
editare sui motori mi richiede il triplo
del tempo che evitare un video normale
che già ci metto due ore per evitare un
video normale ma su motori ci metto un
casino per il semplice fatto che per
tagliare da da una mappa all'altra devo
praticamente smettere di registrare
uscire dal gioco cambiare la mappa e
riprenderla registrare raga un casino
quindi laga direi di iniziare come al
solito io contro i tre stronzi sono il
blu direi di iniziare non mi ricordo i
tasti non mi ricordo non mi ricordo
brutto stronzo cade non mi ricordo i
tasti murray vero primo primo vabbè
terzo dai già qualcosa è perché cazzo mi
ha dato una testata nel culo brutto
stronzo togli the miz viene la gente
addosso se vaime gaza viene che tuo
marrone se vai che cosa stupida bene il
verde il verde e il verde è solito
suicida si fa riconoscere anche nel
terzo episodio tanto per cambiare
raga veramente non mi ricordo i tasti e
preoccupante sta cosa aspettate un
attimo
oddio sono caduto sono caduti madonna
che schierata ok
nel secondo episodio raga mi avevate
detto dico che cazzo fanno sembra sembra
una royal rumble cadono tutti ok ok per
manco solo io l'unico stronzo che non
cade è vero
ok madonna che madonna e cazzo ho preso
ma dragare play ma che cazzo o crema
donna il bianco è morto
ok raga direi di cambiare andiamo su
l'ngf al da chrome e deve essere una
figata assurda perché caduta c'è ad alta
quota diciamo io non mi muovo
fate voi ok se ci godo brutti bastardi
ci godo
e per ferma donna ma che cazzo è mica
siete caduti un po 4 arriva anch'io raga
arrivo arrivo
ok mi sa che ho mancato perfetto o
attorno ma che cazzo l'ho preso dritto
dritto nel bene è stata questo ha fatto
malissimo raga
bene castrato proprio di violenza beh
buongiorno a lei
senta vuole essere volesse ragazzi sopra
di me è perfetto non faccia queste cose
oscene perché siamo in pubblico ok raga
direi provare questo non ho idea di che
cosa sia
però non mi ricordano anche il nome ma
chi se ne fotte bene siamo sempre io il
bianco devo battere quel lurido verme
che vieni brutto bastardo via ma cazzo
ma non è possibile ma come fa
vabbè mi sono sì prendi tra la donna che
cazzo ha fatto il bianco è morto va beh
sì poi subito dopo vado ma raga qua ci
sta tutto
[Musica]
no
siamo su mai infield non ha idea di che
cosa sia dal nome promette bene infatti
presumo che tutti quei blocchetti in
mezzo sia nomi ne va beh devo riuscire a
buttare bianco per lo meno non ci devo
finire io e se io facessi così ok ok no
il brutto stronzo no no no cos'è che
cazzo è successo è bene sta saltando
tutti in aria chissenefrega sono in
piedi o cazzo ho saltato il bianco tipo
capriola troppo epica fatemi riavviare
un secondo perché questa è veramente
fantastico
devo riuscire a mandare quello stronzo
di merda ma devo finirci io c'era
camassa livello quali siamo un po a
catena perché come prendi la prima come
prendi il primo blocco saltano tutti
quanti a catena quindi un bordello
vai vai vai vai vai vai vai vai vai vai
brutto bastardo
brutto stop no no
che cazzo muori bastardo mari ok ci sono
finito anch'io e mezzo alla mischia ma
non fa niente
l'importante che ci addio sarà madonna
che regola si stava beccando in faccia
l'importante è che ci sia finito se
colui che cazzo sta facendo
vabbè cambiamo ma pasto punto si smette
a dean group armi pervertito devo niente
la boe ha un abbraccio d'amico potevi
anche chiedermelo prima se volevi brutto
stronzo
ok vedo oddio cosa sta facendo la cacca
ma che cazzo raga è veramente su motori
penso che sia al top dei videogame che
faccio penso sia cosa sta facendo
penso che sia videogame diciamo al top
dei no sense e dei più divertenti di
sicuro però mi dispiace veramente tanto
che è difficile da evitare perché sono
veramente lo farei molto ma molto più
spesso vabbè cambiamo livello comunque
andiamo con monte non so che cos'è
neanche questo però montagna mi ispira
siamo sempre io e sto bacato di merda
devo riuscire a partire senza cadere per
primo diciamo ma se io mi metto oddio
sta per tirare una testata perfetto è un
genio è un gera che è un genio c'è io lo
compatisco veramente il bianco e delle
ispirazioni fantastiche nel suicidarsi
raga prova a giocare a soccer si chiama
così sto livello ciò paura vado a c'è la
palla che figo
ok brutto stronzo vinco io cos'è questa
italia inghilterra vai io sono l'italia
ovviamente va a verona e fallo dove
l'arbitro quando serve brutti bastardi
l'arbitro è venduto
oddio è fantastico sto livello epico
vincoli ma guarda che è stronzo ma dov'è
il fallo dov'è l'arbitro quando serve
venduti
e cazzo devo ma [ __ ] devo riuscire
a prendere la palla prima di te voglio
sentirmi tifare in curva raga tutti
tutti in curva ma è male azzurri forza
azzurro più che forza azzurri ma non
importa la palla e libera attenzione fa
vj avanza a porta vuota incredibile
inciampa e simulazione ma non c'è
cartellino si rialza giocatore
incredibile fa vigesse appresta a
segnare la porta è vuota il portiere s'è
addormentato incredibile che cosa fa
attacchi spastici lo spinge il bianco lo
spinge fuori dal campo sarò cazzo sta
ballando sta ballando fuori dal campo
sta ballando per i tifosi cosa sta
facendo
che cosa sta questo non è regolare il
calcio è vabbè io vado ma doc e scatto
oddio ha toccato neanche tocca alla di
mano regolare ma chissenefrega tanto non
c'è l'arbitro vai vai vj avanza
incredibile poi genera una attenzione
pericolosamente vicino a porta no
inciampa tirarci un calcio ti prego
tiraggi un calcio no non è regolare
neanche questo veramente ma non importa
fa vigeva avanza verso la porta
incredibile no la palla torna indietro e
rimessa laterale per fare i j che si
porta avanti il giocatore lo stupra
sugli spalti incredibile incredibile in
campo cosa sta succedendo oggi domani
sulla gazzetta di su motori dobbiamo
riuscire a rialzarsi vai forza azzurro
poi tira di un calcio nei [ __ ] che
tanto non c'è l'arbitro vice e così
stupro inca addio spostano di peso vai
così tanto non se ne accorge nessuno
vabbè qui addio che cosa stupida
ok ragazzi riparte il calcio di inizio
fondamentale provincia cazzo
il bianchi i bianchi tirano una facciata
sul pallone ma fa vj tentare di
recuperare palla va vige tenta di
recuperare palla incredibile incredibile
assist da parte dell'inghilterra
sull'italia il colpo di natiche
dell'inghilterra può spingere il pallone
in acque pericolose fa vj salta
sull'avversario ma nessuno si accorge di
niente
la parola in posizione pericolosissima
attenzione lo scatto sulla fascia
manca il pallone non ci credo non ci
credo mancato il pallone devo riuscire a
sorpassarlo fa vj inciampa sul pallone
il bianco inciampa su fa vj è una già è
incredibile in campo oggi che cosa sta
succedendo la palla ancora in posizione
pericolosissima la palla è ancora lì si
appresta a calciare un semi calcio di
rigore a porta vuota
l'avversario è scorretto ma nessuno si
accorge di niente ancora la palla buona
la palla buona per essere presa la
parodia che cazzo mi serve caressa in
questi momenti non so come commentare
queste scene mi serve mi serve un
assistente brutto stronzo
poi c'è l'occasione d'oro il tiro
1 a 0 1 a 0 italia inghilterra stanno
soffrendo
la partita si fa più accesa incredibile
fa vj che gol che gol che resterà negli
annali della storia di su motori che
cazzo gli avversari si disperano è un 1
a 0 schiacciante no ma perché cadi
perché hd in questi momenti cruciali la
partita no levati dal capo dio che cazzo
fa giocatore giocatore più improvvisa
acrobazia sul campo ma la palla è ancora
lì pericolosissima buona per il
raddoppio famiglie riesce
no non mi svenire adesso non mi svenire
adesso mi ha detto chiedo il cambio time
out piano piano piano girati chi calcia
sto maledetto pallone se dai dai che
entro no no no no no no piano
oddio la palla pericolosa levati dal
cazzo portatela dentro fa riportate da
devi portartela il braccio mi è rimasto
incastrato nella porta cazzo non mi
cadere ti prego no no no la palla è
buona la palla buona ma fa vj cade e
bianco 6
il bianco segna ed è dura 0
raga non ci posso credere dopo due ore
di tentativi il raddoppio da parte degli
azzurri dopo un decesso sul campo anzi
fuori campo il bianco per solidarietà
decide di buttare la palla all'interno
ed è 2 a 0 vittoria schiacciante per gli
azzurri fa vj porta in alto il titolo
italiano dopo questo posso chiudere qui
la vj e fabio caressa vi saluta navi
ricordano di lasciare un commento mi
piace se vi dove è piaciuto anche la
pagina di facebook che trovate come in
ogni video nella descrizione
se non siete iscritti iscrivetevi da fa
vj e fabio caressa e tutto e noi ci
vediamo in un prossimo video bella
ragazzi